the x-men might be marvel's mightiest
mutants
but that doesn't mean they have it easy
these characters have suffered some of
the worst traumas the marvel universe
could throw at a superhero
and then some from brutal backstories to
chilling childhoods
these are the x-men's tragic origins
born into privilege as the son of
renowned nuclear scientist brian xavier
charles xavier's life took an unexpected
turn when his father died in an accident
brian's work partner kurt marco married
charles's mother sharon
bringing his son kane into the family
alongside him this all seemed innocuous
enough at first
but charles's psychic abilities made him
aware of marco's ulterior motives
namely that he married sharon for her
money kurt soon began
to slip into alcoholism abusing both
charles and kane
though kane remained embittered toward
his new stepbrother
charles attempted to learn more about
kane through telepathy but
ultimately ended up furthering the chasm
between them
kane eventually became juggernaut his
deep antagonism
acting as a constant reminder to charles
that he failed to heal his stepbrother's
trauma
after serving in the korean war and
having his heart broken by his fiancee
moira mctaggart charles decided to
travel around the world
in the himalayas he disrupted the plans
of an alien calling himself lucifer
who was intent on colonizing the earth
as punishment
lucifer dropped a stone onto charles's
legs resulting in charles using his
signature
wheelchair regardless of these traumas
however charles understands the
privileges he has been given
and how to use them to make the world a
better place for mutants
sometimes we all need a little help
scott summers is typically professor
xavier's right-hand man
eventually seceding the telepathic
founder as the headmaster of the school
for gifted youngsters
but aside from his angst over how
difficult his laser-eyed mutant ability
is to control
scott has a past and a present full to
the brim with conflict
scott's childhood was torn apart by a
deadly plane crash
his parents sacrificed themselves for
their son's safety
equipping scott and his brother
alexander with parachutes
and tossing them out of the aircraft
though both boys lived
their lives were forever changed by the
event both became
wards of the state but scott ran away
after his powers began to manifest
after years of mistreatment scott was
taken in by professor xavier
the fickle nature of scott's mutant
ability is in some narratives
blamed on the brain damage he sustained
in the fall from the plane
while other stories chalk it up to a
mental block created by the trauma of
the ordeal
couple this with this complicated
on-again off-again relationship with
gene gray
and scott has been toting around a whole
lot of baggage over the course of his
life
though scott ran away from the orphanage
after his powers manifested
alexander summers his younger brother
was adopted fairly quickly
the blandings family took alex in in an
effort to replace their son todd
who had been tragically killed in an
accident years earlier alex did his best
to live up to his new parents
expectations of him
trying to become a carbon copy of todd
to help alleviate the pain of their loss
the trauma of todd's death grew even
deeper however
when alex and his foster sister haley
were kidnapped by the same boy
responsible for todd's death
this event spurred alex's plasma
plasma-based mutant powers
into manifestation to protect himself
and hayley
alex ended up losing control
incinerating their kidnapper
heavy stuff for sure but the evil
geneticist mr sinister
helped alex out by blocking that memory
for him
an interesting parallel to his brother
scott's own supposed mental block
a powerful psychic jean grey's abilities
were honed with help from professor x
himself
meanwhile jean's romantic entanglements
and her multiple deaths and reawakenings
as the phoenix have given her plenty of
dramatic allure
to some her telepathy may not seem all
that exciting in comparison
but it is in fact a uniquely powerful
talent with uniquely intense costs
jean's powers first manifested in
childhood when her best friend was
killed in a car accident
the young gene reached out mentally and
linked with her friend
nearly dying in the process herself she
was awakened from her subsequent coma by
professor x
who sealed her abilities away until she
was old enough to control them
though jean's home life was a happy one
her incredible mental powers and the
toll they take on her body and mind
set her apart from many of her fellow
mutants and it was the sheer strength of
those powers
that so often became gene's own undoing
wolverine is easily the most popular
member of the x-men
especially following hugh jackman's
stellar portrayal in the x-men movies
but logan as he calls himself is a more
complicated character than you might
guess
in just about every sense of the word
[Music]
born james howlett in the 1880s logan
has only scattered
vague memories of his past what is known
is that he was born into a wealthy
canadian farm family
but was purportedly fathered by the
family's groundskeeper thomas logan
thomas wound up killing james's adopted
father john howlett
as revenge for being thrown off the farm
it is at this moment
that james's mutant powers first
manifested
bone claws emerged from the backs of his
hands
which he used to swiftly kill thomas
terrified
james fled and adopted his slain
father's surname
decades followed in which logan worked
in a mining colony
lived among wolves and even traveled
with a circus
eventually he was kidnapped by the
weapon x program which fused adamantium
to his bones
empowered by his healing factor logan is
blessed with an extra long life
which he sometimes considers more of a
curse as he is eternally haunted by his
long
and sordid past is there any member of
the x-men who's quite as cool as storm
not only are her powers seriously badass
but her intelligence
battle savvy and excellent hair make her
one of the most beloved marvel heroes of
all time
but aurora monroe's past is a tumultuous
one
led by no small amount of grief and
conflict
aurora is the daughter of a kenyan
tribal princess and an african-american
photojournalist
as a small child aurora lost her parents
when a fighter jet crashed into their
home during the suez crisis
burying the young girl under the rubble
being trapped like that
saw aurora plagued by claustrophobia for
years
a terror that occasionally gets in the
way of her work with the x-men
for a while she was raised in an african
village and worshipped as a goddess
at some point in her youth she met
prince t'challa later known as the black
panther and king of wakanda
the two enjoyed an adolescent romance
that much later
culminated in an on-again off-again
adult relationship
the adversity aurora faced growing up
might have been intense
but she's all the stronger for having
endured it
born anna-marie rogue was raised in a
mississippi hippie commune
the members of the commune attempted to
use native american mysticism to reach
the so-called far
banks but their failure to do so
properly resulted in her mother's
disappearance
rogue was then cared for by her aunt
carrie whose
grief at the loss of her sister made her
a strict disciplinarian
though rogue loved her aunt she was a
rebellious teenager
and ultimately ran away from home roe
grew close to a boy named cody who
after impulsively kissing her was left
in a permanent coma
the first victim of her life-draining
powers the guilt
and the fear of what she had done
weighed so heavily on rogue
that she adopted a completely body
covering outfit that has since become
one of the characters defining features
she was eventually adopted by mystique
and began her mutant exploits with
magneto's brotherhood of mutants
later joining the x-men after absorbing
ms marvel's
psyche along with her cree powers rogues
struggle with her superhuman abilities
as a huge part of her character though
workarounds have been developed
she never quite gets to let her guard
down entirely
some mutants are more obviously mutated
than others and
kurt wagner isn't able to hide his
differences quite as easily as some of
his colleagues
abandoned as an infant kurt was found
and raised by a sorceress
working in a bavarian circus he enjoyed
a happy childhood
as the circus members held no prejudices
towards mutants
and his acrobatic abilities were popular
with audiences
though he has always had his unique
appearance his powers of teleportation
didn't make themselves known until he
was a teenager
these powers manifested because kurt is
actually the son of the shape shifter
mystique
and the demonic warlord azazel his
parents less than
savory reputations have marked him his
whole life despite his own devout
catholicism
after a stint in the freak show in an
american circus kurt set out for germany
to find his foster brother stefan
who he learned had apparently murdered
several innocent children
the townspeople seeing kurt's demonic
appearance assumed he was the murderer
before they could enact vengeance
however professor x stepped in to save
him
despite the complications of his origins
and the prejudice that his devilish form
invokes
kurt is frequently depicted as upbeat
and friendly
proving that some people can push
through their own darkness
and emerged stronger for it who the hell
was this
gorgeous wagner but in the munich circus
i was known as the incredible night
caller
storm we're out of here everyone loves a
bad boy
and remy lebeau has been breaking hearts
ever since his comic book debut in 1990.
remy never had a chance at a normal life
however
having been kidnapped from the hospital
where he was born and subsequently
raised by the lebeau clan
thieves guild he was rumored to be the
prophesied child
that would finally bring the opposing
thieves and assassins guilds together
ten-year-old remy proved that his time
in the thieves guild
was fruitful when he attempted to pick
the pocket of the guild's patriarch
who then officially adopted him the
pint-sized criminal grew into a troubled
teen
working for the fiendish mr sinister for
a time remy went on to marry bella donna
boudreau
the granddaughter of the head assassin
of the assassin's guild
this union of the two factions was
short-lived however
as remy killed belladonna's brother
julian in a duel immediately following
the wedding
remy had to make a break for it but his
colorful past just won't leave him alone
despite this he remains a charming
member of the x-men as gambit
slinging his charged cards at enemies
with considerable panache
as any comic fan will tell you some of
the best heroes start out as
villains and no one exemplifies that
better than the icy emma frost
born into a wealthy boston family emma
was emotionally neglected by her
extensive family
moreover she was bullied at school but
when her psychic abilities manifested
she began a promising career as a
teacher tutoring her peers with the
support of her own mentor
a man named ian kendall her father
soundly rejected this pursuit however
and was further angered by video footage
of emma kissing ian after she discovered
telepathically that he found her
attractive the footage
taken by emma's sister was intended to
be used as evidence to get ian fired
but emma decided to respond by
blackmailing her father instead
surprisingly her father was impressed
with his daughter's strength of will
and offered her the family fortune emma
refused choosing to make her own way in
the world
away from the bonds of her stifling home
environment
emma then entered a period of
homelessness which saw her become the
white queen of the hellfire club
positioning herself directly opposite
professor x and his academy
years later however she would become
co-head mistress of xavier's
school alongside cyclops and sure emma
might be catty
aloof and often judgmental but her
difficult upbringing instilled in her
an iron-clad respect for hard work and
responsibility
she might not always be nice but she's
still one of the x-men's most dedicated
heroes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one